one music video for the next year for
the next year Briona think about six
months no the next year I'm gonna have a
baby
things are gonna happen Thank You the
freaked the [ __ ] out yeah had a [ __ ]
baby wasn't gonna come around is like a
visible and out see with clarity husband
like my name is Gary Thomas I've been
telling you
accounts of equity I'm triple-a given a
pedigree to being in a fleshly specialty
including the works and I'm sure nerds
are moving furniture 11 well or their
subjective call on creative instead of
creating the process that allows more
creative to see the day of life and be
able to see the quant and qual feedback
from it so it's the human beings in the
way of letting more creative see the
world and then reacting to the creative
instead of having ego that was an
individual step it's the creator you
know what I'm sorry you don't I'll try I
can even have it
I can't even add how is it usually
outside
[Music]
can your mental health our heart I know
it's over your body
but I'm never moving I'm always writing
so binary like if I'm on your team I'm
all the way there I just I just stopped
like the put the faucet of like
awesomeness and love and opportunity
just off attitude like that scene a lot
closer probably on this tell me girl for
me that's the trailer always no really
I'm not discussing a lot of labor ring
it's a tortoise and a hare Rick don't
even really don't even it's just don't
be select that you're killing you
entertain me three or four times a
[ __ ] day excuse my language
what is it use my leg your son team for
God's sake but you use will be that you
set me down in the room when I first met
you and I've known use about five
minutes and you said you're going to
have a million followers on next year on
lap I remember and you said no you're
going to you realize what the [ __ ] is
miss kit yet you're like everybody's
going to I know you didn't quite mean
that but like what do you mean I didn't
mean it we were getting one thing when
we were in 315 and I was just building
out that office I knew it I told all of
you [ __ ] what you're going to be so
to me is let's take a step back sure
instead of what you're doing right now
one man's point of view in trying to win
in a way that I think you have left
control sure and the majority of people
are trying to go through that path sure
my question is do you believe that you
can replicate your social reach ways
they think you've got that out of the
chin will sorry I'm not shipping Emily
from
was ridiculous venomous turkey if you
decided to create for musically decided
to create for Instagram create for the
platform not create the romantic thing
you've decided that you are you can
replicate it keep you choose that's the
right move only thing I'm doing for you
because I love you is giving you the
permission to understand that truth I
get it what's going on being plan B is
to be like everybody else in this town
and [ __ ] be at the mercy of
organizations that don't give a [ __ ]
about you
that can't be [ __ ] great what if
you would have horrifying reality do you
mean that's Plan B I'm going to tell you
something yes sir my dad's first
generation green Club and I think that's
what I love you because this is this is
like my father's office except you're
way younger than my dad I'm doing I'm so
hot
[Music]
every day I'm using this for the next
year limiting on me other things about
six months no the next year I'm gonna
have a baby things are gonna happen
thank you don't freak the [ __ ] out yeah
had a [ __ ] baby what you're really no
no you know what the interesting on you
know you know what was more you want to
know what's most interesting about that
moment what you're so good at what you
did and what you do I was able to give
it that stop that think that was
actually incredible moment I consume no
content I know I'm not really I know
that's it
the fact that you have something like
that I'm not going to let you [ __ ]
waste it plug it on there
what the [ __ ] thing the polemical can
be about so for the next 365 days this
man right here is going to be making a
song a day on Instagram who's freaking
the [ __ ] out I can't curse on this
channel you can curse [ __ ] yeah cool
love you man Wow I'm pumped up man you
are where to God on my life I'm telling
I'm gonna say something wired this is
where I guess we are pretty weird
already I will never talk to you again
if there's not a video tomorrow you will
never talk to me ever again I swear on
my children Wow
can you say that I'm optimistic no say
it enough you should this is for you and
me listening having to go oh man listen
listen up I love you so don't go on a
second I really need this go ahead this
is very silly
[Music]
Louisville beer man like I believe in
you and I don't you lose me I do brother
all you're credible thanks guys I'll
talk to you so V desert really I'll talk
to you tomorrow be nice out here
alright don't guys I'm [ __ ] fired up
underwater you're like excited about the
content you're excited about you're
excited about bananas fit in circle
what's gonna be a huge hit but don't
mentors have more experience and
connections yes but if you do work like
and what people don't understand that
really pisses me off is they're not
creating any leverage everything's about
[ __ ] leverage both looking into
[ __ ] jerk-offs you guys had leverage
because you came and work to free that
was your leverage that created your
opportunity people [ __ ] hitting up
people on being like hey more Cuban I
want to be you all want you to be my
mentor with what [ __ ] leverage
[ __ ] so either you go and do it from
scratch and build something that gives
you leverage like a [ __ ] young Mark
Zuckerberg or young mr. Eagle wants to
hit me up and says hey I'm like hey you
build something you got something or you
[ __ ] do something to bring
disproportionate value to the other
person which is the old thing is free
work of a skill that people need but
then everybody cries it goes I don't do
spec work that's the value of me
everybody you know like ridiculous
argument because the value of you is
your whole life not [ __ ] six weeks
six months or a year nobody understands
this is all leverage it's all leverage
people don't want to work man people
want to work I know you agree you did it
so let's get into 430 other 30 or
whatever [ __ ] list you're on
you know it's like there's no [ __ ]
way you were going to do it other than
did something smart like yeah you did
something smart and rogue you can
something even more interesting not only
did you use it to things right you asked
mostly living in [ __ ] ask and you
ain't crow like
you get us twice you ask more than twice
you need to dig up those emails that's a
real [ __ ] blog post you know you need
to find every one of them d-roc you have
enormous traffic
oh hey guys I cut I wanted to I want to
do a 24-hour - and a live globally right
like yeah
[Music]
another
[Music]
yes honey - he has one of the prettiest
things but all your truth baby sell your
truth that's right
possibly two men and proud of us yeah
like I like the momentum you're building
gun you don't know Spanish a registered
guy right look I was going wide yes
row one miss Clara I understand what
write that book a trip for three years
they would scale up big good morning
america was able to scale up from that
now we're life is hard
I just do
how much everything we keep that tonight
but one beaming really resonated with me
was how you talk about how we can
control our hustle I get so many people
asking how do you accomplish it I do
that other than that your work
yeah anything else you want to my
channel Gary yep work
[Music]
he did it a lot of fun
Big Ups la there's a bus look hope you
guys enjoyed it yeah
hey guys yeah a good day no I'm not
tired I'm gonna catch me sweep them ever
again
oh I will I will
[Music]